[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the latest developments in the sarah
lawrence college sex cult federal trial
larry ray
effectively
did what prosecutors described as a long
night of torture and from the olympics
to an attempted murder trial i'm taking
my life back we take a closer look at
the case of michael barassone plus mr
zaminski instructed mr rosenbaum to get
him and kill him that's what i heard a
key figure in the kyle rittenhouse case
faces trial in the same courthouse but
first is a new trial in the cards for
convicted killer scott peterson the
latest developments out of evidentiary
hearings in california lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer along with me in new york as
always is terry austin we begin with
news out of california as convicted
murderer scott peterson's defense team
works overtime to score their client a
new trial evidentiary hearings concluded
on friday for alleged juror misconduct
now that means that the choice whether
peterson is granted a new trial is now
in the hands of a california judge
defense attorneys for peterson called a
total of four witnesses during a series
of evidentiary hearings held between
late february and friday of this week
the prosecution didn't call any
witnesses the hearing stem from alleged
juror misconduct at the hands of
rochelle niece dubbed by the media as
strawberry shortcake now niece served as
juror number seven in peterson's 2004
trial at the time niece indicated she
had never been abused while filling out
her jury questionnaire but she later
admitted she was involved in multiple
domestic disturbance incidents at least
one of which happened when she was
pregnant defense attorneys say that that
constitutes juror misconduct and their
client should receive a new trial a
series of evidentiary hearings for that
motion began in february where niece
took the stand she told the judge she
filled out the jury forms accurately
saying she never considered herself a
victim she also said she never held the
murder the murder against peterson but
did admit to writing to the defendant
after his conviction in 2004 peterson
was convicted for the 2002 murders of
his wife lacy an unborn son connor he
was sentenced to death but the
california supreme court later threw out
that ruling and he was then re-sentenced
to life in prison peterson has always
maintained his innocence well joining us
today of course is co-host terry austin
but also criminal defense attorney
nicole the board all right nicole i want
to start with you
what do you think the odds are that
peterson's actually going to get a new
trial and if he does
what is that going to look like what can
we expect
i think that the odds are reasonably
high
jury
information like this can be substantial
error you are counting on honest
responses from jurors and it's really
difficult to uncover uh many times in
the post-conviction phase that a juror
has said something to get onto the jury
that is false but in this case they've
got the information she's admitted that
essentially she was a victim even though
she didn't consider herself one in
several domestic violence cases um even
though she didn't disclose that on her
jury form and then ultimately ends up of
course convicting peterson so i think
that this is something that the court is
going to have to weigh very heavily and
very possibly will rent a new trial well
terry you know what's interesting is
that rochelle and she received immunity
for her testimony it's not something we
haven't seen before so what could happen
to a juror who were to testify without
immunity
you know if you don't have that immunity
you really can be charged with contempt
of court or obstruction of justice these
are the types of jurors they're called
stealth jurors they're trying to get on
that trial they have a hidden agenda
they want to influence the outcome and
we're beginning to see a lot of this in
high profile cases we saw it with gelane
maxwell and these jurors want their 15
minutes of fame but in my opinion they
really should not get immunity they
should be held in contempt because every
defendant has a sixth amendment right to
a fair trial and if there's a new trial
it costs a lot of money so we need to
take it seriously that's absolutely so
well said no matter the defendant no
matter the case everyone is entitled to
a fair trial and i can't believe scott
peterson's name is in the news again but
we'll see which way it goes all right
turning now to news out of new york the
legal aid society filed a class action
lawsuit this week pertaining to the new
york police department taking dna
samples from suspects without a warrant
or court order the legal aid society
calls this a rogue dna database the
lawsuit is filed on behalf of clients
shakira leslie and shamil burgos and
others who had had their dna entered
into a suspect index without their
consent now neither leslie nor burgos
have been convicted of a crime there are
more than 32 thousand profiles in the
index with black and hispanic
populations being the dominant races the
dna is being collected from the person's
cigarette butts and cups of water
attorneys for legal aid argue a
violation has been made both of state
law and fourth amendment rights which
protect from unreasonable search and
seizure nypd sergeant edward riley made
a statement saying that the department
will in fact review the lawsuit
and now an update in a story we first
brought to you here on long crime daily
the california couple charged with the
death of their two adopted sons are
served criminal protective orders in
connection with their other children
that means suspects triselle and
jacqueline west cannot see their two
biological children and two remaining
adopted children without supervision
without supervision and only once per
month this comes just weeks after the
west were indicted in the deaths of
their adopted sons three and
four-year-olds oren and orson west the
boys were reported missing in december
2020 and their bodies have never been
found prosecutors now say the west
killed their adoptive sons months before
they were reported missing they now face
charges of second-degree murder cruelty
to a child and false reporting of an
emergency
still ahead on law and prime daily we
take a closer look at the coming trial
of michael barrasson the one-time
olympian now accused of attempted murder
but first before kyle rittenhouse fired
his ar-15 prosecutors say joseph
zaminski fired a shot in kenosha
wisconsin and jeanette levy's here with
a look ahead at zaminski's coming trial
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back everybody the riots in
kenosha following the police shooting of
jacob lake in august 2020 created tens
of millions of dollars in property
damage and soon the trial will start for
a rioter who fired a gun on one of those
nights and became a key figure in the
trial of kyle rittenhouse long crime's
own and jeannette levy has more on
joshua zaminski's case
joshua siminsky faces several charges
related to the riots in kenosha
prosecutors say he set a dumpster on
fire one night and also fired one shot
in the air he's also charged with
obstructing an officer zaminsky can be
seen in videos from live streamers who
were recording that night kyle
rittenhouse's defense claimed at his
trial that joshua zaminski instigated
the confrontation between rittenhouse
and joseph rosenbaum rosenbaum is the
first man that kyle rittenhouse shot
that night
mr zaminski instructed mr rosenbaum to
get him and kill him that's what i heard
rittenhouse testified he feared for his
life and that rosenbaum chased him as
seen in drone video after he throws the
bag and he continues to run he's gaining
speed on me a gunshot is fired from
behind me prosecutors say zaminsky fired
that one shot in the air seconds before
rittenhouse shot joseph rosenbaum four
times
neither prosecutors nor the defense
attorneys called joshua zaminski to
testify at kyle rittenhouse's trial but
at a recent hearing zaminski's lawyer
told the court that he would take the
stand at trial and claim that kyle
rittenhouse is the one who started the
entire confrontation when he pointed his
rifle not only at him but also joseph
rosenbaum for law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy
all right so terry nicole we have a lot
to talk about here terry the charges
against siminsky are clearly less
serious than the charges that were
leveraged against written house still
same kind of event same courthouse you
think there's a possibility he's also
going to be acquitted
jesse i think there's a very good
possibility that he might be acquitted
listen the written house jury thought
that kyle rittenhouse had a right to
break the curfew he had a right to
defend himself with that weapon and
zaminski's charged with misdemeanor use
of a dangerous weapon because he had
that weapon and he shot it in the air so
they thought that was a misdemeanor but
he's also charged with the arson but i
think a jury at least in kenosha
wisconsin is going to think everyone was
breaking the curfew people were starting
fires listen he was out on bond for just
a thousand dollars his wife has already
pled
guilty to similar charges she's serving
seven months i think the prosecution is
trying to make a point here but we'll
have to see whether the jury believes
that point should be made i don't know
terry the case of self-defense this
might be a little different but we'll
see now nicole what are the odds that
kyle rittenhouse rittenhouse himself
could be called to the stand and testify
as a witness in this case
i think it's entirely possible his trial
is over and he now has no exposure
unless they argue that potentially
others could be investigating charges
which i really don't see at this point
so he no longer has that right to remain
silent if you will because his case has
concluded it's entirely possible that
they could call him to testify on the
one hand on the other hand uh
the prosecution really he would be
interested in calling him because his
side would potentially align more with
their side uh may just be done with
written house and decide that it's too
much risk to call him to the stand at
all
it would be interesting to see that's
the the very least uh some great
predictions so we'll see where it
ultimately turns up in the zaminsky case
uh coming up on long crime daily we're
gonna head to new york where the accused
sarah lawrence college cult leader faces
more than a dozen charges in federal
court plus a one-time olympian will soon
stand trial for multiple counts of
attempted murder we take a closer look
at the charges michael barassone now
faces
[Music]
and welcome back to long crime daily we
look ahead now to a trial out of new
jersey where a one-time olympian faces
multiple counts of attempted murder it's
trial you can see on the long crime
network live with our gavel to gavel
coverage
michael barissone faces two attempted
murder charges stemming from the
shooting of lauren kanerick this comes
as part of an ongoing dispute at
barrison's long valley farm in upstate
new jersey at the time of the shooting
barristone was training kanerek as a
dressage rider but their relationship
soon turned sour when she became a
tenant on his property kanrak lived
there with her boyfriend as part of an
agreement of using barrisone's farm
facilities in training under him a
string of 911 phone calls were placed
from both parties leading up to the
shooting
okay tell me is that what happened
these people are
on our place they have been living in
our house in one of the apartment units
they are clients here at our horse
stable this situation is getting worse
and worse and worse the police have been
here twice in the last three days
they're nuts they're stalking us they've
they're harassing us last night there
was a facebook post which is what this
woman does she's
a minute okay
the facebook post says
my split personalities are going to take
over and i am not control of what they
do we are in fear for our lives
opening statements are expected to be
presented in this case next monday
so terry an attempted murder charge
seems kind of hard to prove what does
the prosecution need to bring forward in
order to get a conviction here
well like he said we're in new jersey
and they define attempted murder as the
failure to commit the murder and what
you have to prove basically is that the
defendant intentionally tried to kill
someone else and basically they have to
show that there was preparation for that
act that there were substantial steps
taken towards the act and then the
victim of course must not have died i
think in this case we will see that
there were substantial steps taken
towards the act we'll see how and when
he got that gun we'll see
the fact that he actually did shoot one
of the victims twice in the chest so i
think that those acts were taken towards
the attempted murder i don't think
they're going to have a difficult time
proving that specific charge as long as
they can put him in that place at that
time so we'll see what happens but it
looks like a strong case to me well
nicole let's assume the prosecution can
prove the case what kind of punishment
could barriston ultimately face
he could face years in prison as a
result of you know attempted murder
essentially so i mean this is an
incredibly serious charge
it's obviously not murder because the
people who were were involved
even though shot in the chest survived
so we're left with the next sort of
level of reduced charge which of course
is the attempt
and just because the complainant or the
victim did not die does not mean that
you don't have substantial criminal
liability and that is exactly what
barristone has in this case
and terry you know it's it's we have 10
seconds self-defense you think that has
any play here
i don't think it's going to have play
but they're going to play those tapes
and i think he's going to say he thought
he might have gotten attacked so he was
trying to protect himself protect his
family protect the farm
it's an argument i'm it's just shocking
to see where someone started and now
where they're ending up so many years
later but it's a trial that we will
definitely follow
well this week on prime crime it's all
about the mysterious disappearance of
victoria prokapovic in this strange
nobody case the question becomes did she
vanish on her own or was she the victim
of a murder the answers may lie in the
multiple interviews with her husband
james
first thing i did i jumped in the truck
and i rode every road
i went up and down
because she does like to go for a walk
jim why are you so certain that she's
not coming back
i just had that gut feeling roman i
don't know
it doesn't make sense if you know us to
run off
she would take some things
if she was to hurt herself she has no
means of fighting about it
you can catch new episodes of prime
crime every friday at 5 30 and 10 30 pm
eastern here on the long crime network
when we come back long crime network's
adam classfeld is inside the courthouse
where accused cult leader lawrence ray
stands trial the latest developments in
the sarah lawrence college cult federal
trial
[Music]
after five days of testimony on the
stand the prosecution's star witness
finishes her testimony in the sarah
lawrence college cult federal trial this
comes as defendant lawrence larry ray
faces 17 federal charges including
racketeering and sex trafficking the
charges stem from allegations that rey
facilitated and led a cult at sarah
lawrence college dating back to 2010.
that's when prosecutors say ray moved in
with his daughter who was a student at
the school now officials say ray
befriended several students and abused
them for upwards of 10 years prosecutors
say he extorted money from the students
forced them into sex and prostitution
and even held manipulated manipulative
therapy sessions for days jurors heard
from alleged cult member claudia jury
who says she earned more than two and a
half
million dollars while acting as a
prostitute for rey she also told jurors
that ray emotionally abused her and even
tried to suffocate her
along crime network's adam classfeld was
at the federal courthouse friday as jury
concluded her testimony he joins us with
a closer look at the cross-examination
and rebuttal of her testimony
as the
testimony concluded we had
cross-examination
by larry ray's defense attorney federal
defender who wanted to
essentially paint this as a
more
consensual
affair that she has asked a series of
questions pointing to the witnesses
previously stated views of sex work
there was an exhibit that went into
evidence where she apparently said in
2016 sex work is awesome asked about
that on redirect examination today
she said well at the time when she said
she was under larry ray's spell
that she basically identified herself in
two ways in her life
one was the way larry ray tried to
make her believe that she was someone
who poisoned people um we heard this
again in testimony over and over again
not only with uh claudia drewry but with
a previous witness that larry ray would
somehow convince these students that
they were poisoning him that they were
damaging his property and
basically forced them to pay what
he had convinced them that they owed so
according to drury today there were two
things in her life that she identified
herself with when she was under a raid
spell being a poisoner
and being a sex worker and of the two
uh
at the time in 2016 sex work was much
better for her
disturbing allegations right there okay
nicole i'm gonna ask you a twofold
question one how do you think the
prosecution's doing so far and two if
they actually are able to convict rey
what kind of penalties is he going to
face
it's again an incredibly serious crime
and he could be looking at many many
many years in prison
for this and i think that the
prosecution is doing a good job here of
painting a picture of someone who is
indeed
uh disturbed and dangerous in the sense
that you know you have an adult man who
moves into a college dormitory and then
starts uh to work on manipulating the
people around him that is the picture of
this
defendant that the prosecution has so
far been able to paint so i think
they're doing a good job
see so terry let me ask you this if he's
convicted and goes to prison that's one
part of the chapter being closed you
think about the alleged victims in this
case if he's convicted i mean could
there be any payout to them at any point
do they seek any kind of remuneration
what could happen there
well absolutely they should seek some
sort of enumeration if in fact he's
convicted and even if he's not look they
could bring a personal injury lawsuit
against rey and they would also be able
to bring this is my favorite cause of
action intentional infliction of
emotional distress and what they have to
show is that there was actual harm
either physical or emotional and there
would have to be actual damages i think
based on all of the tapes we've seen all
of the testimony so far it's been
riveting testimony there's no question
that there was actual harm to these
victims and they certainly should be
able to bring a civil case now they
could also bring a civil suit against
sarah lawrence the university and that
basically would be based on the fact
that they failed to provide adequate
security why did they allow this man to
live on campus he had a prior record
jesse no way he should have been allowed
to live on that dorm something's not
adding up yeah it's a i've never heard a
case quite like this and maybe that's
the reason so thankfully nicole terry
thank you so much everyone out there
thanks so much for joining us here on
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you